[Musica]
se fosse ancora
so cosa sia
[Musica]
lo sapremo
un amico
sì che usano rabat
paolo guerra
[Musica]
su cosa buona famiglia sono panda
sopra usa una paura
[Musica]
tutti e due istituti buoni
già stamani dovere si è iper
fenilalanina mia di tipo atipico questa
è una malattia rara ma quanti di voi
conoscono
quante sono le malattie rare
c'è qualcuno che sa la definizione di
malattia rara qualcuno ha avuto a che
fare con una persona affetta da malattia
rara
parlo di persone quello che voi avete
visto non è quello che noi siamo
abituati a vedere da quando da novembre
dicembre sulla raccolta fondi per la
ricerca sulle malattie rare
perché c'è anche queste persone sono
importanti sono persone che vivono la
loro vita e che vicino a voi possono
avere delle dei problemi possono avere
dei bisogni ma non sono a chiedervelo
perché non si vedono
ed è per questo che è importante che io
vi racconto la mia storia
io sono la mamma di laura campionessa
paralimpica a shanghai del 2007 non
parlava non camminava non aveva problemi
autistici gli ho dato gli strumenti oggi
lei non è qui perché stanca di sentir
parlare di malattia rara
tommaso l'avete visto senza il farmaco
tutto ciò che avete visto nel video non
avrebbe potuto fare e quindi stiamo
parlando di che cosa
un valore della ricerca valore del
farmaco quanto è importante ma quanto è
importante che siamo in grado di capire
che le malattie rare sono una sfida sono
una sfida di che cosa
di tutto quello
che riguarda il sistema sistema della
ricerca ma il sistema di dare voce a
queste persone quindi dare un valore un
assistenza sappiamo che abbiamo anche
delle regole
abbiamo sempre sentito parlare di
stamina come metodo e abbiamo sentito
parlare di ricerca ma che cosa dobbiamo
fare siamo tutti invitati a fare l'en
power mente una parola difficile quanto
la iper finali nel mia di tipo tipico e
l'empowerment che cos'è individuale
quando noi dobbiamo fare valore tirare
fuori quella valore dell'esperienza che
quotidianamente alla persona che vive
con la malattia rara per dare questo
valore alla ricerca per essere
paritetici ai medici e alla ricerca
organizzativo perché da soli non si fa
nulla
le risposte si hanno da che cosa dalle
varie organizzazioni che si mettono
insieme a far sistema ma secondo voi
esiste relazione sociale che fa
migliorare la qualità della vita delle
persone affette da patologie rare esiste
ed è lenta ugualmente di comunità
quando dopo si riesce ad avere un
diritto esigibile si riesce ad avere una
legge vuol dire che siamo riusciti a
migliorare quella qualità della vita e
noi tutti abbiamo un ruolo nella nostra
vita non ho scelto di fare la mamma di
ragazzi diversi con malattia rara
diagnosticati magari in età adulta
non l'ho scelto questo viaggio voi tutti
andate ovviamente in una agenzia
pubblicitaria o andate in un'agenzia di
viaggi e chiedete il vostro viaggio
preferito io ho dovuto arrangiarmi sul
mio viaggio che mi è stato assegnato che
era quello di essere una mamma rara però
la fortuna e stata di essere organizzata
era un'organizzazione che era
federazione europea c'è
un'organizzazione che la federazione
italiana delle malattie rare che c'è una
impresa sociale che si chiama uniamo
goldin non c'è un progetto molto
importante che è fantasia e fantasia che
cos'è fantasia è il sapere che arriva
dalla conoscenza di che cosa della rete
delle malattie rare
noi abbiamo tanti centri di eccellenza
che sono in tutta europa e in tutto il
mondo non possiamo avere l'assistenza
vicino a casa ma dobbiamo fare in modo
che quella scienza arrivi alla persona
alla sua funzionalità della vita
quotidiana
e così abbiamo fatto
abbiamo cercato di fare impresa
un'impresa quindi che dalla sapere
arrivasse al sapore e quindi abbiamo
cercato di fare questa fantasia come
progetto unico che è sostenibile perché
è la rete che la sostiene la rete della
conoscenza che diventa innovatività
perché non c'è l'assistenzialismo noi
facciamo informazione e facciamo che
cosa l'inclusione lavorativa le persone
arrivano dal mondo della diversità nel
nostro ristorante ristorante che a
venezia ed è quale voi poi potrete
assaggiare degustare qualcosa che un
altro che i bigoli in salsa e così
abbiamo cercato di fare con qualcosa di
trasferibile ed è successo perché da
venezia centro storico i vicoli size
sono arrivati a castelfranco e quindi
meglio di così
diamo possibilità di dare un qualcosa
che effettivamente è unico l'unicità sta
che quei medici vengono dove in quel
ristorante dove ci sono dei ragazzi che
non è detto che abbiano diagnosi ma che
possono poi avere un futuro di diagnosi
e di vita
laura ci ha messo 12 anni per avere la
sua diagnosi di una malattia rara
che doveva essere screen ata al momento
della nascita ma c'è un 2 per cento di
scarto quindi perché perché quella iper
fedina linee mio era di tipo atipico e
quindi può succedere che sia negativa
anzi che positiva ma tommaso ci ha messo
vent'anni per far capire i medici che
lui era diverso che la sua malattia che
è uguale a quella della sorella si
manifestava in maniera diversa
quindi la domanda è ma quanto la scienza
sa quanto invece noi sappiamo
trasformare il nostro valore di
esperienza alla scienza
parliamo di centralità del sistema verso
il paziente e io ho fatto questo ho
capito che dovevo mettere attorno un
tavolo le persone e così ho fatto li ho
messe tutte attorno un tavolo e quindi
compresi dalla gola con il cibo
abbiamo fatto quel brainstorm che io
spero che succederà anche a tutti questi
ragazzi questo è special olympics italia
a venezia
moltissimi di questi ragazzi potrebbero
avere una malattia rara perché molti non
hanno ancora diagnosi molti non possono
fare quello che ha fatto tommaso o
quello che ho fatto laura perché tanti
genitori non hanno quella forza di
uscire dalle case e di chiedere aiuto
quindi la cosa che vi chiedo di fare
adesso è questa di guardare le malattie
rare in ottica diversa che non è solo
quello del conoscere e il telethon e ho
fatto anche parte di stamina sono
network delle biobanche di telethon
ma quello che vi chiedo adesso è di
prendere alzare le mani
facciamo le mani
adesso ognuno di voi il vostro pollice
toccherà il pollice del vostro amico e
vicino a fianco benissimo e questo è il
flash mob del 28 di febbraio che è il
giorno raro delle malattie rare
quindi l'appuntamento è a martedì grasso
del 28 febbraio del 2017 e grazie
[Applauso]
[Musica]